full of International Affairs here he is
the author of several books including
McCarron and Palestine the boundaries of
jihad and most recently and published by
the University of California Press
apocalypse in Islam the comment will be
the Korean grad P who needs no answer
that the can we give her a round of
applause for back focus on that's far
west small type of the Eurasian word
island known as Europe or Western Europe
in particular and I would also mostly
focus on when looking at Western Europe
on the countries that participated to
the project if you will of European
integration normal internal developments
such as franco-german relations and
external pressures such a difference of
the code word are normally mansions to
explain the emergence and the main
features of Western European politics in
general or soft Western European
integration what I would like to do here
what is to focus on the pub that
decolonization had on less than European
countries and in particular I would like
to focus on one single event in 1973 oil
shock that in so many ways at least
according to me can be considered as the
last episode of decolonization of the
deep
case as you can be conceived as an
effort to gain economic independence by
certain countries after that political
independence had already been obtained
previously and also the 19-foot wheel
shop is a key event in the Mediterranean
region during the Cold War Europe so
before starting up on what the kind of
impact this Porsche cabin Western Europe
we must stress something about the
nature what what was actually the 1973
old shop because much of the literature
on international relations explains the
four-fold increase in oil prices that
can be considered as a main effect of
the of the oil crisis as a consequence
of the arab-israeli war and as an Arab
reaction to the material support offered
by some Western countries men in the US
and Madeline to Israel against the
armies of Egypt on sphere I think this
is not the way we should look at the
other truck yo a shock is something much
much more dust and important than this
it was not something more vast an
important it wouldn't because that he
know the books about contemporary
history as a turning point in the
history at least of the Western world in
fact it had three main elements into it
the first element constituted yo shot
was your embargoed in their meeting in
wait on october 17 of 1973 arab oil
producers arab oil producers decided on
a general 5% production cut to be
followed by another five percent
increase in cuts each month and this is
what they said I open commas here until
it and
the Israeli withdrawal is completed from
the whole lot of territories occupied in
1979 1967 and the legal rights of the
Palestinian people are restored
furthermore the altec countries that is
the Arab oil producers established a
total embargo on the delivery of oil to
unfriendly nations supporting Israel
that is mainly to the US and once again
to the langevin I would argue that this
element of your shot is the least
important of the mode because they only
invited did have important psychological
methods I mean there was a lot written
on the newspapers about it but in
reality in the real world of the energy
market no country was particularly
effective the grommet in fact certain
countries and specially Iran Nigeria and
even Canada increased production to
compensate for the loss in in the
ointment then there is another element
with your shop which is proof of crucial
importance actually it's $12 one link to
the other one is increase in oil prices
in December 1973 and the second is the
nationalization of energy industry and
one cannot understand the other without
taking the 202 together I won't explain
the reasons which are quite complex why
when in advance of 1973 oil prices were
already raising there's a whole amount
of reasons that explain why the oil
market has changed from a market where
con su
decide what rises to a market where it
was producers deciding or crisis i will
add but oil prices were increasingly
already before the realities ready group
and nationalized the nationalization
process even that had started as we have
heard before the arab-israeli war
algeria had nationalized its own energy
industry 1971 was not the first country
to have done so one may even rego that
mexico had done the same thing in the
1930s but still was the first Arabic our
country to do that but from 1971 290 75
all the county oil producers had
nationalized their oil industry that is
conservation oil producers progressive
all producers arab oil producers non
arab oil producers then it's waylon and
iranian that are not Iranian not olive
oil producers at both nationalized
they're their own fellow in the oil
industry and why did they do that that
was to gain control some kind of control
over de become the third element of Gilo
shock was broader in what it also
involved the struggle to create what
somebody also he referred to as the
struggle for a new international
economic order the battle for an
increase in oil prices and recovery of
economic independence by all producers
was openly linked to account back by raw
material producers to reform the order
that have emerged in bretton woods 94
that's a whole lot of elements
explaining this kind of solidarity
between oil producers and the rest of
developing countries even countries in
the non-aligned movement in the first
summit of the non-aligned movement in
September nineteen seventy three hours
before the outbreak of the arab-israeli
war boom again her already managed to
focus the attention on the action of the
movement on the fight against economic
neocolonialism and the non-aligned
movement had embraced nationalization it
had embraced the idea to fair prices for
raw materials and still while holding
the presidency of the non-aligned
movement Algeria promoted the sixth
meeting of the generosity of the UN
enabled 1974 that is the famous assembly
where this declaration for a new
international economic order was raised
but it was not only arab oil producers
linking the battle for a following to a
more general battle to change to reform
some patterns of the global economy a
very important role is the role played
by the next whether you consider that
the venezuelan oil mr. Paris Valero work
he was a former miss your voice and in
73 he was the head of aunt and United
Nations conference for trade and
development that was fully a part of
this battle for a new international
economic order and eventually files
Guerrero became in 1975 also the
co-president of this conference for
international cooperation also known as
north of dialogue that was meant for ax
or debates on raw materials development
and so on support if you consider these
three elements of your shock in 1973 can
we say that they had an impact on
Western Europe yes they had the the oil
embargo did affect the foreign policy of
Western European countries it helped the
drafting on november six of a
declaration of the european community on
the rise of palestinian one can even say
that from 1973 there is a certain
consensus that will probably change
later but an emerging consensus of all
Western European countries with the
possibility shell exception of the
Netherlands of on a floor of the
potential foreign policy at the same
time the oil embargo speeded up the
float a process that was already
underway actually of the elaboration of
the first and only document ever drafted
defining European identity an effort
which led in on the thirteenth December
of 1972 to this declaration on European
identity which had specific reference to
the cryst Oracle links with the
countries of the Mediterranean and the
Middle East and it actually uses of
dying through dalian because through
that has been mentioned so much time
here abroad alien language on a more
strict diplomatic a level oil embargo is
also was instrumental in the setting up
of the euro-mediterranean dialogue at
the beginning of 1974 it forced the
completion of the global mediterranean
policy we should practice word aight
bilateral
women serve with eight different
countries of the Mediterranean signed by
the European community between 1976 and
nineteen seventy-seven the oldest things
might or might not have had a
significant on the long run but they did
mark as a change to the situation of
before nineteen seventy vida was in so
many ways dominated by mainly colonial
approach to the countries of
Mediterranean the second element of the
oil embargo increase in oil prices are
not and the nationalization processes
even this they raised enormous they
raced an enormous impression on on
European Western European public opinion
on political leaders but I would also
stress that it had quite a different
effort to what it had in in the u.s.
because by so many Western European
politicians of the time actually what
had happened seen as an opportunity not
only something you had you had to fear
it's your shock have to highlight the
public awareness on the question of
growth that's when everybody writers
intellectuals politician were requesting
the idea of growth and whether growth
only had to meet increase in production
and that was a lot of speaking about the
quality of Road the limits of drones the
relationship between growth and the
environment with
roads and society at large and basically
was maybe the socialist the Western
European socialist leaders people like
Brandt like Pam and a crisis or some
point is very important meeting between
these dealers at the end of 1973 they
actually agreed in this meeting in
schlangen but in december 1933 on the
need for an increasing role for the
state in order to invest in things that
such as railways as opposed to the car
industry the woods helped redefine roads
and redefine the road for for the same
but it was not only a european thing the
canadian prime minister get to do not
only created the national oil company in
97 but he was part of this debate about
an increasing role of the state and
different role of the state if you will
oil prices also had the effect of making
deal bilateral agreements between
western european governments on single
old countries explode that's the time
the middle of the seventies of the
agreements between the French and the
southeast the French would be to buy oil
for 10 years and in exchange they will
give weapons food to the Saudis it's not
the time of the market is quite a lot
the time of the state intervention in
the economy and also for example the
thinking of italian communist when evil
building where the chief of the
Communist Party brought about austerity
the protocol the politics of the
austerity in the second half of the
1970s its own leads to this debate
generated also by me very oppressed the
third aspect in which the oil shock
effect Western Europe was even in
its diplomatic struggle for a new
international economic order even this
affected the way in Western Europeans
acted in foreign policy it led for
example to the French government the
French president she's got the son he is
convening in 1975 of the conference for
International Economic Cooperation also
known as north-south Dada which ran from
nineteen seventy five to nineteen
seventy-seven a conference where issues
relating to raw materials to development
so that were all taken together and if
you win the creation of the g7 as a
Western place where to discuss
international economy is
incomprehensible without looking it in
parallel with the creation of the count
with the convening of the conference for
International Economic Cooperation the
French government and the German
government openly linked the two they
wouldn't have agreed to create a g7
without the u.s. agreement to create
face other this other conference but
also this debate on the new
international economic order and the
pressures coming from in one in that
moment scheme the common front of
developing counter was crucial in
explaining the innovative nature of the
Loom an agreement that the European
Community signed in February 1975 with
countries from Africa karaganda and the
Pacific it was another difficult
disagreements included a guarantee for
export earnings and this kind of
structural guarantee forest
returning earnings was very much
something that those countries are not
only acp countries but the rest of third
world countries were asking from Western
governments since the 1960s let me just
I mean this is a short story and his
math episode let me just try to from
this too let's hit it can lead to some
conclusions I'm triangle so to base
myself and what I heard previously I
think yeah the Cold War was basically
the framework in which many of this
interaction between the North and the
South of the Mediterranean took place
maybe the Cold War was not empire
building by other means because in so
many ways up here we have heard before
we can even say that the Cold War I mean
the fact that there was a competition
between the Soviet Union and the u.s.
didn't help decolonization but we can
say as I heard before that the main
thrust of the Cold War was at least into
the seventies the increasing role of the
US individual and as such the code word
certainly explains the limits of the
Western political iota of Western
European political autonomy in the 1970s
and if possibly explains the failure of
the euro-mediterranean dialogue at the
end of the 1970s and posted it also
explains why intra-european relations
got more difficult at a certain time but
that is not to say that the Cold War is
or can be seen as the main explanatory
factor for
happening in the Mediterranean at
something like you're shocked actually
renders the connections and the
reciprocal influences they are delicate
they're not influence is going to just
in one direction that they're not
influences going just from Western
European countries too many Iranian
countries yes there's something coming
back this that that's the novelty of the
colonization the influence is not
anymore as I'm colonial times going in
one direction there reciprocal
influences and something like your shop
renders it only more visible so I think
that the how looking at the
Mediterranean can help us in three
different ways of thinking what we're
thinking at this and also thinking at
something like your shop at thinking
what we're thinking in this conference
in the first place it can lead to
reconsider the importance of the world
world as an exclusive explanatory doctor
for Western European also foreign policy
choices after the 1960s and bring in the
consequences of decolonization first
secondly can contribute to stress
generation and Mediterranean dimension
of less than European foreign policy but
it should even want you to stress that
dimension of European society and of the
persistent role of wings of a culture of
a political and of economical nature
established during the colonial times
and rescind even before that even though
after 1956 this country's European
countries might not have been any more
the main military actor in the region
and 30 I would like to suggest to column
historians that is the
the historians the study European
colonial empires not to end their
analysis of the foreign policy of four
former colonial powers in 56 that's what
they normally do they go up to nineteen
fifty-six and then they say okay France
decides to participate in the European
integration process so it's historians
of the cold war or of European
integration to study France know they
have to engage in the later period even
though the spirit is different than them
before and I think one particular yeah
one particular issue on which colonial
soldiers to duel and that has never been
mentioned here is the way in which
things like emigration affect the
movement of people from one part of the
Mediterranean to the other half which is
linked so much to the building of
colonial empires before change affect
the European politics and European
foreign policy in the later period from
the seventies eighties and nineties and
that is very visible even in a country
like Italy today thanks thank you well
thank you all for your standard your
presence which is so good to be here
because
not a wonderful huge that of you
wonderful day is not on the street in
Cairo and winter Manhattan but it's a
whole cycle personal cycle because these
conferences are they call the sequel to
the one that Victoria ishida poppy and
the last babe as the international
diplomatic academy in Paris and this was
a very morning where I know that I got
the visiting professorship at Columbia
so blessed when I don't know we need
good feelings so you are interested I
stand between you and well deserved
relief so I won't be long and I'm going
to focus to collateral casualties of
common law attorney Catania just a step
down that about I'm talking about the
magnifications and a by argument is that
the French Israeli relationship was
badly damaged because of the logic of
Cold War and two periods and we'll
discuss the wood and metal so very
different in both I will address it from
the point of your friends world vinegar
the presentation by openly about how
Israel
roadies request strategy position as in
the best ally of the United States
region and I was very conscious and
articulated strategic choice and it
clashed with friends in those two areas
and celebrities as either of the war
downtown we are not stunt of those
Americans who just returned to in fact
that dealing with what is the heart of
the caloric is the integrity of Europe
anti-american 33 during the missile
crisis of Google and famous exchange
between the wall and the Soviet
ambassador at its Ladies Day any
government has a very strategic tall and
life saver so I'm going to lunch massage
and this and that and so the goal
varying the golden say well
holiday to Moscow by the inverter
sending meet them all doing the same
questions of ladies when Sparrow
socialist in Germany pacifist ER deze
famous college and all besides our
Easter and pacifist are in the West as
you've already absolutely the deployment
of pressure inside of her German stolen
so they were certainly cold warriors
when it came to Europe and America but
they conceived the survey was possible
official individually and this clash
totally with this repetition in most
cases and especially this is French
touching special relationship with
Lebanon because I know if only to
prevent accumulation that can be crushed
by so-called walk by the week party and
in some cases and so on both cases they
are pretty big supporters of this way
which is why I better start rental
solutions recording ology that we
destroyed and no and thread quite
actually built legend the now about
French betray relationship one in fact
most of the conscious choice by this way
to change also because if you talking
about the 60 and I'm thinking about the
rule about talk about the turn
it on Marie Duval in under the board's
at 22,000 stellar 17 years three were
sold chappelle comedy cocktail new
generation of time during the most times
at 385 tons of uranium were delivered to
Israel which as we know and to be very
sophisticated
so sophisticated that the United States
intended to monitor support see over
there were of course function that sub
single school at the same time the goal
is the same for me they're advocating
for full implementation of UN
resolutions your own choice then you go
order the statute government is that
France is powerful because it is a
permanent member of the Security Council
true but there are mobile society that
the United Nation where's the place
where neutralized sent I believe them
between America and Soviet Union I mean
that case the most pathetic an emphasis
was right here it was calling for the
four powers China and you will really
see receiving the video despises as a
sideshow of the main cold war raging in
Indochina and you know how critical emos
in the northern speech in 60 61 certain
American forces would never achieve it
to it so it was afraid that he was a
trigger the simple speaking often about
that and it's a few and we need content
of Indochina then we are ready for
disaster so friends I did you
seven was consistent with more and even
more from natal integrated this more
independent stem wasn't pretty missable
in trust by the Communist Party why he
generated debate remarkable in right
wing which speak internationalist and
programs and policies and why it's the
select between the American Socialist
and the soldier comments so during the
month of May nineteen sixty-seven you
see very clearly that France ask for
scoot away in the 79 we think the cast
out by student arenas infiltration from
siliguri twist we're afraid it will
trigger the major country as a pushing
for for power over at the United Nation
to deter the conflict and you are at the
same time instruction from the goalie
the invoice especially attuned when to
avoid 85 not tight initiative that first
America and Britain that would be
perceived as hostile by the Soviet Union
it was a time when look at our station
soldier Cameron all-important retreating
military confrontation between Israel
and neighbors in order to strengthen its
all of Earth's climate social so he
founds the French where towards
Russia the Gorn could never speak all
the way up you know always spoke about
possession so the four powers for man
was a French omelet dreams of Russians
in at also to neutralize anglo-saxon
theater initiative at that time our
research British Prime Minister
reciprocally Android for our to Georgia
data escort a that manipulate the
freedom of negation and navigation in
sedation of uncommon but on the mail
which aids selection procedures so that
Prime Minister want to go about the
crisis in the Middle East and it's
carved in the party's possibly offended
for powers consultation and it could
also blame on the US administration so
the world go to this river st. was
aggravated of course whether the same
time didn't phone back on the tripartite
format that cigarette and it was the
same value in the question june and the
position will make very clear today by
visiting the role that would make even
clearer
of the country of June second when there
was statement by the government
committees presiding vice president's
chair by the president and the statement
such the state that the first word
producer weapons no matter where not
expect Francis approval and certainly
not it's supported by exam and spider
fact that after 24 hours everybody knew
that you say that started the war and
those associates old intervention while
back you know is responsible for or
aggression so what I'm going to do the
world may look at the iterations at
crucial point need an authorized on jun
7 1 delivery of all materials including
crucial spare parts for the nearish
fighters that Israel Adobe be paid for
it was only after and to decide
achievement that means every delivery to
Israel came to another so during this
offensive its agent Jordan and Sarah
Israel never worried about French
military supply and one would say very
property is that which record
this one so at the same time faced with
a military disaster agent try to
convince friends of the United States
and and with them I'd let air support to
the Israelis for fancies this was a tie
one American Embassy comes related
cultural centers went up in flames all
over the world because NASA and said so
so you might leave the post quite
natural at a time bands are also the
time when there was the various type of
pain building in illustrate any to
United States the gate friends
backstabbing Israel during the country
despite that the goal can be very close
with ya a most a soft cloth with the
National village more yes than in da
Kissinger is easy oh my god he resisted
so impression to sanction the Jewish
state and the sodium countries was very
strong medium and there it is incredible
incredible meeting face-to-face meeting
on huge wins custody Soviet party the
third of its way to the UN General
Assembly in New York and when we should
a vicious attack identity and so I would
just put the part that the whole thing
it's more goals than I would imagine so
the gorgeous that figures the movies
already speaking comes next it's only
the notes
the next crisis and he say that either
is no settlement if such an agreement
could not be reached the Arabs we try to
get revenge they will accumulate force
is to reverse what took place so United
States with support Israel in this
competition in this arm competition
there they'll be very serious
international complication since you and
the United States would text size of
this issue and would soon appear on the
right side sensi that erupted in very
literally that Israel means nothing and
that the rivalry between Americans and
Russians is the heart of the matter so
you can beat the Golden can be the
savior of France and be totally wrong
when it comes to three days that that
was really east asian you know so and
it's incredible foul is called war
vision led you to adopt antique called
hologic in the widget because he wanted
to avoid the sheer consequences of this
Corvo logic but what we need topped
everything goes when israel raided to
the airport on this number 28 1968
destroyed the civilian immensely other
retaliation again to palestinian
on an Israeli play the special
relationship between France and epidural
I'd been targeted for Sullivan on walls
you'll need threaten able to escape
neutral during the six-day war and
Israel are completely used French many
cultures to strike at the example that
was what made the world mad because I
they used to guess I you gather to
destroy java and you know that something
you shouldn't do so the order of food /
military and our group on Israel a
little more than 18 months after the end
of the 767 so the whole of ours formula
absolutely the long-term vision of the
world letting welcome in mesa state the
first yet that peace conference Becky
you try to keep for clarity this
radiography didn't develop YouTube a
little more since it clash with Israeli
preference and Israeli military
establishment at long before you do plan
to switch to the United States as a
critical supplier of advanced Griffin
choosing for instance the pattern that
the donor French give em a certain so
just duration of the crisis in 67 and
the dramatization of the straight face
insert in each state intensifies
accusations against France when they
will refuse to lend support to able to
alien crafts described since your region
of the risks
when control of Israel when the board
keep choosing the stab them in the back
Jewish state fight fight survive before
he spoke to French our policy well of
course decree what does just be
presented by your shop or that upper
left result it all sounds dialogue and
in fact so the real Gorean is that
settlement speaking about control of
yours is not even police veteran status
who goes we need to push a logic poses
new purchase ensign works at Venice
declaration and make that is Rupert
response to into tenderly agreement and
again we should clash Israel also miss
america and which for the first time
difference the full-fledged campaign for
sanction vote by forcefully supporters
against an inch both of them so maybe
our because a friend that gives us the
second good oh of course you have Europe
you have beautiful being active
your position are fresh drafting
physician no and I saw dr. the French
who come to yoga consisted of events so
when they say the Venice Venice so you
have white or some determination and
suppose but when it's me down say let's
continue that suddenly varies and when
we do we'll come back and say that's a
piano national right and so on we have
also this is joy to explain why I'm
focusing on front and not on the border
your community because this is basically
anyway so just again Cold War watching
here it's not their narrative
relationship but they would have and try
to manipulation video as the central
proclaimed the builder of the Francis
trading relationship and committing
infertility swear in his first year
stated the first state either to the
holy land since King bowie knives steps
of proportion that was the way it would
put them in the aerospace the first
agreed since shall we wondered with some
so
the Crusades a guy it was before media
anyway so you had all these that even we
focused exhibitors aware because be
giving a child a plaque and that one was
dirty and was totally line and this is
what I said before Sierra a pillow
associate problems it again and here are
the best ally of the United States you
cold war and the Melbourne fashion on
behalf of America and he wrote in your
old warriors is of course a little bit
more enthusiastic than the other I like
something like being the toughest talks
a lot and therefore so we reach it was
routine and friends try to play it off
another partition 20 minutes are up so
you should i wait yes so the whole idea
was that as I trying to do love you
noses UN resolution for
the neutralization of the root jun of
penalty to the better for television
then you are the multinational force to
create haha then coming back after
savage satria but it was even worse
because the control logic when food it
will self fulfilling prophecy because 17
on mobile phantom will send the
incredible amount of weaponry and
advisors to to Syria and we know at one
moment the whole Cold War by proxy
really happen in the country by children
at Apple to steppin out of the super
harvest refund for time in September 83
by the work so that a lot of people one
hour you betrayed out in Odessa and you
must go arrested before even diminution
and you know p is equal to waste and all
that or coming with Soviet you know
training Soviet at the other side the
famous general are would defend the free
world with a new jersey you know
cruising and so in that case not only
friends will smash the Tories French
relation and second of the list was
freedom because the molar in shock you
know dissident movements could not be
counted because of Soviet tax in Syria
you got when a pretty happy better
go and it was trying trying to protect
us from so the whole control logic went
again full-fledged and just mentioned to
as part of course drugs Israeli way on
50 that was supported by America and in
America supporting an aggression of
Tunisia for something totally valid and
fred was only worth trying to do to try
to improve temple this logic and always
trying to push at that time with no
passion for 304 powers in the mall
because a Preparatory Committee for
international conference for pieces at
least and last point is of course when
the cold war ended and a friend sort and
determines would close the opportunity
to read and review and sponsored key
process has been in Stratford that of
course pretty active that Thomas Patrick
adviser to some these fans and I've seen
the way
to New World Order Pax Americana 150
percent you know and that was many you
know is a just a sweetener for these
last two weeks so French Israeli
relationship standing in damage and of
course pores are due to scoot on friends
but also one could also the dates nose
so more like here for hours about
un-sponsored is person I know what
really beautiful because the in fact
made sense you in the world war as an
accident at the moment civil war was
over some ways I feel like we've come
full circle here a very big circle
started like thinking about the problem
co-worker Mediterranean with this
subtlety of election campaign and then
effort to relaunch a euro-mediterranean
that that one felt so read the world of
college dear colleague nerves Ghassan
Salim a Lebanese now head
who's the School of International
Affairs of friends which is tied to
Columbia to applaud here and what Kate
seemed to be very clear is he omits
awkwardness and this French strategy
things this do call as strategy of
Sarkozy very know that k you're not for
them to not deal with the Palestine
Israel question directly because it
really won't be involved we will try to
deal with the problem turkey by putting
turkey not us down then we will use our
special relationship historic
relationship with Mediterranean to speak
to the Mediterranean francophone gesture
and of course it's also deal with
setting a framework so revealed
capitalism it's not exactly being
certain lots of capitalization
financialization of small-time
development important the southern part
of the Mediterranean African sore
around and this would reintegrate Europe
and the Mediterranean so quite quite
remarkable at the same time you couldn't
hear the been attorney and speaking yes
that sounds like a great idea many ways
a very colonial gesture Albert so this
kind of response of 2007 it harks back
to okay what happened I guess my initial
problem was Europe being separated or
the Mediterranean separate that that's
already met sally Orientalist vision
europe venturini but yes also what
happened in other words how did the
great powers shifting around i will
accept he's bigger Longer this is great
powers moving around as part of the
story because under all the nations of
peoples who are acting illness and so is
I hear the two papers i guess i'm not
sure if it's contesting or elaborating a
narrative that i might set up like this
to try
try to position two papers coming out of
the 1930s there had never been probably
more significant they may be so worldly
fill in a second but certainly the
integration across the Mediterranean if
you want to call it the big imperialist
culmination of incoming period Lizabeth
first half of the 20th century there
couldn't have been more connection old
connection Jewish communities around
that really interested tack but they
were still around there were commerce
and then you know tallies wanting their
empire the reviled revival Roman asst
the use by Frances Algerian North Africa
for food there was a lot more
integration economically in there had
been before reinforced by all kinds of
barter other Imperial relationships and
the large amounts of money also grew in
Ali's enjoyments were drawn as well so
pretty good quite a lot of those
competition and actually digression and
that's broken after World War two so
initially and I would agree with you
it's not broken 45 is not broken in 48
Italians pushed away diplomatically and
it's not 56 it goes beyond it sets of
movements so there's a whole history
which one could call decolonization and
the question is is it ever separate from
appointment oh he was making this is
justin grimm powers in other words you
could say cold war from the deck up 45
the battles are set so there's always a
question
what is a relationship between
decolonization and cold war and I had
some trouble unhooking saying you've got
decolonization and you've got cold war
and so some around some points I can
just sort of raised raised the question
clearly you know 1956 let's
decolonization Cold War the Cold War is
acting there and that's a very kind of
huge bridge for the overreach of the
British and the French and it's always
been our big payoff for the French as a
result of the Suez more was European
integration the road for 56 for 59 58 is
very quick so there's a kind of turning
in and the big payoff man is stop being
a miraculous empire which very low
growth rates and you in German to
Western Europe and integration and you
enter a different very different kind of
D market using the local resources with
a lot of pull back of Kappa something
that I don't think it's been study I so
knew about a supermarket capital
invested in Europe apparently does come
from withdrawal colonial capital like
Suez so
you've got a lot of capital has what
most valuable investments we could plant
has been distribution a second point
theory is the development of European
community that clearly yes it's got a
configuration it's a condition by the
Cold War probably making ways that you
can't say if european common market
agricultural policy is a result of
connected the Cold War what started as a
Norma's fact especially with an American
model development comes in which is
based on petroleum being distribution
which favors very much European sort of
European agricultural development and
also by the distribution chains that
don't use North African all for food for
products from around the Mediterranean
they're coming because the scale from
South Africa or for Israel from the new
era T's where you can have a more
advanced agriculture and that it comes
out how to's work the way the
agricultural policies are set up as
enormously damaging to North Africa
along with my false because look we
change of machine agricultural regimes
with at the capital investment this
area's so that's if you want another
area of separation and then I think you
can go on that we find these days 67
after the wars the expulsion of the
Jewish community of her
that's a form that complete form it kind
of cross Mediterranean connective tissue
that's very very debilitating and then
we can go on to 273 the oil shop now
there i'm just i'm not sure if those
policies add up to much incentives and
sets reactions and i wonder if that
doesn't that make up to your work that
they seem they have stronger roots and
effort to create a postcolonial or a
neo-colonial settlement